[MUSIC]
Good afternoon, good evening, or
perhaps good morning, wherever you are,
I want to welcome all of you to
today's panel, Your Journey.
Now I know, 5 Years Out, so
we're going to be speaking to
some GSB alums who graduated
in the class of 2016,
in our five years post graduation.
Today's event,
I'm going to just give a brief
introduction to our global community.
I'll talk a little bit about the alumni
population in representation
of the GSB around the world.
I'm going to introduce our panelists,
in fact,
I'm going to have them
introduce themselves.
And I have some Q&A for them,
just to start off things, to hear their
experience about their time at the GSB and
for them to share that with you.
But I also want this to
be somewhat interactive,
as interactive as we can be on Zoom.
So if there are specific questions you
have for the panelists, either off the top
of your head right now or something that
comes up as they are sharing and speaking.
Feel free to ask that
question in the Q&A pod.
I'll be monitoring those,
you have the chance to upvote those, so
if someone asks something you also want to
hear the answer to, feel free to do that,
and I'll try to monitor,
we'll get to as many of those as we can.
But we do have just about 15 more minutes
together, so this time usually flies
right by, and like I said,
we'll try to answer as much as we can.
So, and with that, the GSB alumni,
I hope that the five folks or the four
panelists joining us today can attest
to the fact that it's a strong network.
But numerically, it's 30,000 plus alumni
globally, represented around the world.
There's actually 60 volunteer-led
chapters that are regionally based.
In addition to that,
there's also diversity chapters and
different programs to support women.
I'm curious to hear from Hiral and Emily
whether they're involved in either of
those, but our women's circles is a strong
program in place to just put women after.
And in addition to just the network
that I'm sharing about right now,
there's also support that
continues beyond the GSB.
We'll talk a little bit about the role
that CMC might have played in helping our
panelists secure there are jobs or
positions post GSB.
But there's also support that
continues after being a student too,
and so
we can talk a little bit about that.
With that, I want our panelists to
go ahead and introduce themselves,
I have a little bit of information
up about each of them.
But I want them to kind of
go through who they are and
what they were doing before the GSB,
and where they are now.
And in addition to just introducing
yourself, you guys, if you don't mind
sharing with the group today, what was
perhaps your most impactful experience.
This could be a course that you took or,
of course, you took or
just an experience you had whether it was
travels or something extracurricular or
personal, whatever it may have
been during your time at the GSB.
I will just go across where the names are,
so Emily, you are first.
>> Amazing, hi, everybody,
excited to be chatting with you all,
also excited to see all my
fellow alums on the call.
So as the slide says,
I went to Yale undergrad prior to the GSB,
I spent a lot of time at Bane,
Bane and Company Consulting, and
worked predominantly
within the retail space.
I also worked a little bit
in the Non-profit space.
And then after the GSB,
I went back to Bane for a little bit but
I also had fun times in Startup Land and
Apple, and
then have landed back now in
the design and retail world.
So that's my current employer
is F.Schumacher & Co.
You see this awesome wallpaper,
that's actually Schumacher & Co.,
and I had so many amazing memories and
full experiences.
I will talk probably about
just a trip to India,
actually, that I took.
So, this was actually coordinated and
organized, similar to a GST,
I mean, sort of copied a GST.
But it was with one of the people that I
became very close to, Barat, in our class.
And he is an amazing Indian man
who took us all around India.
But what was so special about it is that
it was this really diverse group of people
from all over the world.
And but cared and loved his country so
much and
getting to experience it through his eyes.
Was truly super memorable, and
I still remember all of the amazing meals,
all of the moments with politicians,
all of the crowded street corners.
And I'm excited that all those
folks are still very close to me.
>> Awesome, thank you so much for sharing.
Hiral, would you like to go next?
>> Yeah, it's so good to me to
everyone from all over the world.
And I know people are staying up late or
waking up early for this.
Hi, my name is Hiral,
I am originally from India.
So I grew up in India,
did undergrad back in Mumbai, and
then US being at the forefront of
innovation and tech brought me here.
So I studied Computer Science at
Carnegie Mellon, and then joined Apple.
Really working on some of
the first generation products,
I was in software engineering,
very much heads down.
If some of you have iPhone,
I don't know if I can claim yet,
but if you could make a call
that was because of me,
at least a decade ago,
I don't think that's true anymore.
GSB was fun, I did venture capital,
I tried impact and everything, and
came back to realizing my heart is still
in technology and building things.
So I continued to be on my journey
to be more product, management and
product leadership.
So currently I'm at Amplitude,
overseeing kind of a product team.
For those of you not aware,
Amplitude is a product analytics company.
So we build products,
fast tools for product managers,
it's just a great place to be.
That respect to my favorite experience,
I think I'm following Emily's lead here,
travel is a big part of GSB.
You'll all realize that, and
so some of the memories and
fond memories always come from there.
For me, one of my fondest was when
we went to a chip to Russia and
Serbia, so I did see someone from
there as well, which is awesome.
I think this was not an official trip led,
but two of our classmates are from Russia.
And I think for me, the biggest thing is I
would have never otherwise gone to Russia
unless they lead a trip.
But we also went in March,
so when we were in
the rural parts of a we've
seen frozen lakes.
We also did ice skating on
the freshwater lake called lake Baikal,
and the whole sight and spending time with
the classmates was the most memorable.
We had visited the provider
like the news communism.
So, understanding a lot from that
perspective, from the locals perspective,
was very eye opening versus
hearing what you read in media.
And then, yeah,
classes wise there's always a lot more we
can talk as we evolve the conversations.
>> Sounds good, thank you,
Jon you're next.
>> Hello everyone, I'm Jon.
Similar to Emily, I also also went
to Yale, I studied physics and
mechanical engineering, and then did
a Master's at Penn in robotics after that.
So as you can probably assume, I have
focused a lot on technology and robotics,
Both after undergrad and after GSB,
and spent some time at MathWorks,
which is the company that makes MATLAB,
playing around with
some of their toolboxes and
building a robotics product there.
And then, yeah, GSB,
I switched my focus from being an engineer
into doing more product-oriented stuff.
And since then I've been at
a couple of different companies
in various parts of the robotics industry.
So I was at iRobot most
immediately after graduation,
which is the Roomba company,
working on some of their Roomba models.
And, subsequently, I was at a company
called Virtue Gray, which is a industrial
automation provider, which actually
recently went public two years back.
And most recently,
just very recently, I joined Waymo,
which is Google's autonomous car project,
so to speak.
So, yeah,
GSB was obviously very influential.
I think we would all agree that
there's a lot of different aspects
of our GSB experiences that
we'd love to highlight here.
I think that, for me, I agree.
I think travel was one of
the more impactful things.
But I'm going to highlight
what's called a GMIX,
a Global Management Immersion Experience,
that I did during my summer.
Where, I went to Buenos Aires to work for,
I think,
it was a little over a month or
so, at a company called Wormhole,
which does online,
it's an online education platform
similar to Coursera or edX,
but for Latin American market.
And they're a small company.
They still are a fairly small company.
But at the time they
were just under 30 folks.
And two of us from GSB went there,
and we got some scope.
It was my first experience doing
anything product management related and
it was amazing to learn it from
the folks at the Argentine company.
And we were really brought under
the wing of their leadership team,
which was a very rewarding and
special experience.
Because not only did they
introduce us to their product and
their way of doing things and were very
open to hearing our perspectives and
we were able to contribute and
learn a lot.
But they also helped introduce us to the
culture and we got to do a handful of fun
activities in the city and
really have quite an experience, so.
>> Awesome, thank you for sharing.
Jason, do you mind introducing
yourself and sharing also?
>> Of course, hey everyone,
my name is Jason Scott.
Sorry, I'm coming to you from mobile,
so if my phone falls, it's my fault,
not yours.
But I am currently at Google, but
going all the way back before GSB.
So I went to undergrad at MIT, and
I was actually in biological sciences.
Definitely thought I was going to be a
doctor, at that point in time in my life.
And then ended up, really, as many
people do towards the end of my college
experience, really not knowing
what I wanted to do in my life.
So I end up in consulting.
But luckily, the part of consulting I
was doing, I was doing innovation and
R&D consulting for big companies.
And really, at that point, I realized that
I loved kind of the idea of exploring
something from scratch, or
something novel, or something unchartered.
And so, had the realization, I was like,
actually moved to San Francisco and
start working at startup.
So, I ended up taking
a job at a startup and
also applying to business
school at that point in time.
Really focused on learning
about entrepreneurship and
trying to fill that gap, and
I was lucky enough to get into the GSB.
And, really, since then, my career
has all always been about startups.
So ended up working in venture capital for
a little bit at Highland Capital Partners.
Doing some entrepreneurial things on my
own, and then now leading a lot of our
starter work here at Google, and running
a lot of our accelerator programs, and
some of our angel investment funds,
and things like that.
So, really fun work.
I also hearing everyone,
I'm probably back, so
many of my favorite memories were just the
one-on-one connections that I have with so
many of the individuals and those chances
to have those authentic conversations and
hear people speak so
passionately about their journeys.
And I remember actually, Dan,
I don't know if you remember this, but
I remember actually meeting you, in our
first admin welcome event in Boston and
learning about the work that you're doing.
And just being, so, a nod and having
these conversations with individuals
who are just so passionate about so
many different spaces.
And I think when I think about my favorite
GSB moments that was one of them, right?
Whether it's the large group scenarios or
the small group scenarios, the talks or
the trips, or even just the casual
lunches with someone new in Times Square.
It was just hearing people speak so
passionately about areas that I knew
nothing about, whether it's media,
or fashion, or retail, or robotics.
And so that was what was magical for
me about GSB, and still is the kind of
diversity of perspective,
expertise, and kind of passion.
>> Awesome, thank you so much for sharing.
I do want to just, for educational
purposes for those on, some acronyms were
mentioned that I want to make sure
everyone understands what they are,
because there's a lot
of acronyms at the GSB.
And so the GST was mentioned,
this stands for Global Study Trip.
And then GMIX was mentioned, this is
a Global Management Immersion Experience.
And these are two ways you
can fulfill another acronym,
which is your GER, which is your
Global Experience Requirement.
So, a big component of the learning
at the GSB is not just in classroom,
which next question, just to tee that up,
might be about a class that impacted
you guys [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned about academics.
But which is fine, but
also a big component is
hands-on experiential learning and
getting out of your comfort zone.
So that idea of, embracing, like what
Jason said, the diversity of perspectives,
and that can be done in a lot of different
ways, whether it's conversations or
travel, and that is something that is
hugely embraced and encouraged at the GSB.
That said, so, our academics.
And so I'd love to just circle
back with you guys about,
perhaps, you're five years out now.
You all took the foundational courses,
but you also,
because it's a general management program,
took electives,
pretty soon on in your first year and
then all of your second year.
Were there any classes that you
found to be the most impactful,
either during your time here and
you don't use it at all now, or
just as you are five years out and
you are in your organizations and working?
Is there anything you look back on that
has helped you so much from the GSB?
Let's start with John, this time.
>> Sure, so there's a bunch of
classes that I would list up here.
I think, probably, the most impactful is
one called Managing Growing Enterprises,
which I think for a lot of folks,
I think a lot of folks would agree that
that was a pretty impactful class.
This is one where it's very case-based.
But, for me, the special part
of the case-based bit was that,
more often than not, the protagonist to
the case would join in, in the class.
And, at least, for the first class,
it was a bit of a surprise.
They don't tell you that
that's what's going to happen.
But, I think, in the course of
going through the different
challenges that each of these
entrepreneurs faced when they were
building their businesses,
you learn a lot about the way that they
thought about it versus the way
that you would think about it.
Because the method within
the course is The instructors
will often effectively
role-play the scenarios out.
And it teaches you a lot about
effectively good ways that work and
ways that don't work for
handling difficult conversations.
And other kind of like personnel and
sometimes strategic related things that
come up just on a day to day basis.
And while the focus is
a lot on either startups or
executive level stuff,
you end up with a perspective
that cuts across lots of different areas.
And you can apply it even immediately
after GSB, it doesn't have any relevance,
it doesn't strictly have relevance
to things five, ten years out.
So for
me that was the most impactful of course.
>> Great, thanks for sharing.
Hiral, do you mind sharing a course
that impacted you or that?
>> Yeah, definitely,
before I share I like to Bill and John's,
the managing growing enterprise,
definitely something we carry for life.
But for me the most memorable for
that one was because I role played to
fire someone as a board member, and
that someone who is a CEO Chairman,
I was working for him three years later.
Just imagine the situation, you fired
the person in the class to not be the CEO,
but he still is of course,
and [LAUGH] now I'm working,
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is Kevin he really teaches at
the GSB as well.
But for me like one of my most favorite
class, there are definitely several but
there's a class I took the last quarter
was called Art of Self Coaching.
It was with Coach Khaled which I think
he teaches a lot of different things.
But it was like it helped me sum
up my GSB experience a lot and
how to carry that forward and continue
to have the learning even after GSB.
So he went a lot into just happiness and
reflection and
thinking about it, which Julie summarized.
And I still follow his blog a lot and
from time to time ask him a lot
of situational questions.
He's a coach to a lot of executives
at startups and tech companies.
But for me that was the most reflective
class that helped me kind of put my entire
experience together, so highly encourage
when people get in to take that one.
>> Thank you.
Emily do you mind sharing yours?
>> Sure, someone has to do it and
I'll do it.
My really impactful class
was Interpersonal Dynamics.
Touchy feely, I think it's called
interpersonal dynamics, right?
>> It is, I know, yeah.
[LAUGH]
>> It's what I remembered it as.
I honestly like all classes like that,
those are the classes that
I really appreciated.
So high performance leadership,
things like coaching
all my fellows classes.
I think because so much of why I came
to business school was to work on my
own confidence, and work on my belief
that I belonged in the business world.
And so much of what those classes
accomplished for me was a real space and
time to deeply understand myself and
that's such a rare thing.
And such as kind of selfish thing
in some ways to be able to spend
two years understanding that stuff.
And I think now as a result of those
classes, I don't remember a lot of
the like really specifics of the finance
classes I took or anything like that.
I'm sure there's going to be another great
example from other people with that.
But for me those classes are why
I'm the leader I am now today in
the organizations I'm in because
I know who I am, because,
I know what I want other people to
feel like when I interact with them.
I'm cool with the things
that make me emotional and
I'm cool with the things that make me, me.
And all that stuff is like very hard,
I think,
to learn or to give yourself space to do.
And so I will forever be grateful for
the time to do that and
have Stanford enabled that.
>> Awesome, thanks for sharing.
And Jason, is there anything else to
add about a class that impacted you?
>> Mine is somewhat polarizing for
both current students [LAUGH] and
some former students.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And even for myself, but
the class that I say to this
day that I remember and
think about the most was this
class called Path to Power.
It talked about power and influence and
understanding your power and
influence within scenarios.
And I think ultimately where I came out is
how to make sure you use your power and
influence for good, and
are conscious about that.
And so for me, I sit in meetings all
day every day, where I'm thinking
about influence and what are the power
dynamics in those rooms.
And how do you make sure that
you're conscious of them and
intentional about your behavior and
how it might influence decisions and
how people feel, I guess,
and so using power for good.
And not having power be a bad word,
I guess is also something that I think
a lot of us took away from that class.
>> Awesome, thank you for sharing.
Yeah, I feel like the examples you
guys all gave, especially the Art of
Self Coaching and Interpersonal Dynamics
and Paths to Power are also a highlight.
Another thing that's really
important to the GSB experience,
which is the idea of developing
yourself as a leader at the GSB.
You can get schooled in finance and
strategy and
things like that in a lot
of different places.
But really developing yourself
as a leader to go out and
manage people in organizations is
a key component of the program here.
I'm going to ask one more questions and
then I'll start kind of taking
them from the audience.
So I thank everyone for
posting their questions, I'm seeing them.
And this actually relates to one of
the ones that's been uploaded, but
you guys are all five years out.
And you came into the GSB with an idea
perhaps of what it is you wanted to do,
maybe or at least maybe what you
wanted to get out of an MBA program.
And so, just seeing where you are now,
and this is somewhat of a deep question,
but are you where you thought you'd be?
And for those who maybe are, that's
awesome, we'd love to hear that and for
those who have pivoted or
changed, we want to hear that too.
And I'd also kind of infused in that
answer if it has impacted you a bit,
like what role has the Stanford
network played in helping you in
your five years post GSB?
So we'll go backwards now,
we'll start with Jason.
[LAUGH]
>> You gave me the literally, I was like,
please don't start with me, [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> But no, no, no, it works.
I mean, no, I think in short, because
I don't think I knew where I would be.
And I think as you do in many situations,
you get around all these
amazing people and you go through
the journey of do I belong here.
Am I supposed to be here?
And then you get the confidence back and
such.
So I think the idea of where I
would be in five years changed so
much throughout the GSB.
But I think ultimately,
I'm still chasing my north star,
which is what is the ultimate,
what was most important.
And I think, really, when I look back
to the answering the question of
what matters most and why, I think
I'm still headed into that direction.
Even though what I do functionally
on day-to-day basis is not,
I have no idea that this is what I
would be doing, I think back then.
But to the power, I think your last point
is what was super important for me.
I think, I think I even underestimated
the power of the GSB network.
I to this day, even within my,
not just people within my class but
even when at work and
I find out someone was a GSB alumni and
then all of a sudden we're best buddies.
And then we're collaborating and
things like that.
And the network is so powerful and
it truly has created such tangible value
in my life, in my career and I wouldn't
be where I am today without it so far.
I mean, maybe hopefully I would
have made it some eventually but
I definitely wouldn't have
gotten here as fast so
it was definitely catalyst in that and
so highly appreciate it.
>> Awesome, thank you?
Emily, why don't want to go next to you?
>> Okay, I also want to say that I didn't
say this at the beginning but also one of
my key memories is always dancing on
the dance floor with Jason Scott.
He is one of the best
dancers in the world.
And every wedding I've been to with him is
the more fun because of him, every party
at the GSB is more fun because of him,
the square was more fun because of him.
So anyway.
>> I need to afford that answer.
>> Yeah, Cool.
He can do it all.
He's a renaissance man.
I think I know, I mean, yes, I had no
idea where I would be in five years.
I had ideas and thoughts that like,
I was very passionate about retail and
I was passionate about consumer and
I wanted to go to Stanford to connect
consumer to like the future
of innovation and retail.
So that in some ways, I think has played
out which is interesting, although I would
have never expected to be at a home
interiors company and slinging wallpaper.
But I do think that what I
would say is that stamp like
the Stanford Alumni Network
has been like instrumental
to every career choice I've
made posed to the GSB.
Every moment where I was thinking
about leaving or staying somewhere,
the first people I called
were my GSB colleagues.
Whether it was Emily or Sarah,
I think I want to go into a startup but
I don't know which one, you're VC,
tell me the ones that are good and
tell me the ones that I
should stay away from.
Or I don't know, just even sharing
any of my life moments now,
GSBs are the people that
I want to do that with.
There are two GSB in my living room
right now, drinking tequila and
eating cheese while I'm on this call.
So, the network are my
sort of cornerstones,
the touch points that helped
me to decide what's next.
And to help me reground myself and
who I am.
And I think like to Jason's point,
I still think I'm like for
sure on the journey of what do I
want to be when I grew up, who am I?
But I feel very, very fortunate
that I have all these humans in my
corner that are both experts in their
fields or who've just know me so
well that they can say like Emily,
no, you don't want to do that.
That doesn't sound like anything
you would ever want to do.
So, no to being where I thought I
would be five years from the GSB,
but yes to Stanford being exceptionally
instrumental in my current life.
>> Awesome, thank you.
I'm Hral, why don't you answer that next?
>> Yeah, so I think for me, I didn't know
I want to always stay in technology, but
not exactly know what function or
job I would be doing.
So, I think when you ask this question,
I think most of us entered GSB
writing an essay, but
definitely still figuring things out.
I still joke that I think one of
the reasons I went to business school was
because I didn't know
what to do with life.
[LAUGH] And thankfully, that helped me
at least discover what I don't want.
So I chose more of a path of
elimination to figure things out.
But one of the things were
just really helped and,
I think accelerated a little bit
of how what I would have thought
about especially when it
came to managing people, and
giving me the confidence to raise
my hand and to ask for what I want.
Whereas prior to that,
I think going back to Emily's point,
confidence is definitely one of
the things GSB helped us with.
It definitely broke us down in the first
quarter but then helped us build it.
I mean,
just having been in engineering and
all those definitely very much like
an IC contributing things, but
quickly right after like six or nine,
eight months after GSB I'm hiring people.
I'm going back and
hiring from the GSB hiring from elsewhere.
And I wouldn't have had
the confidence to do that.
Or even put my name in the hat like last
year, switching to corporate strategy,
doing more strategy working for
chairman CEO directly.
So I think that's probably where I see
where the five years out has helped me and
I still see lot of my friends
have done Master's in CS&R.
Where I stand is quite different and
a lot of that I attribute to the GSB,
the network for sure, but also just
the confidence in built in to go ask for
things.
>> Awesome, thanks.
And John, do you want to chime in there?
>> Sure, yeah.
So, I had a couple of short
term goals going into the GSB.
Which have been generally
as fairly tactical and
trying to execute on those which was
to make the conversion into from being
an individual contributor engineer and
to being in product.
And starting to think about things
in less of a kind of narrow,
technologically focused way.
But broadly, everything that the other
panelists may classmates has
said resonates which is it's very hard
to put a five year plan out there.
I did certainly do that,
[LAUGH] because just
kept some general goals.
And I don't know,
I think have worked out in a way that I'm
really happy with, but
I can't say that I planned it.
In terms of GSB alumni involvement in
the first job, I got GSB through iRobot,
I was introduced to it by reaching out
to a GSB alumni who work there and
had a conversation.
And the funny thing is this,
actually, I applied for
the job originally without knowing anybody
and was rejected almost right off the bat.
And then I reached out to an alum
who is at the company and
immediately got a conversation
with the hiring manager.
So, it's funny how that works, [LAUGH].
And then the second job that I
had out of GSB after iRobot,
I had been with the company for
a couple of years.
I kind of learn the ropes of what it
takes to launch a consumer product,
and had gotten a couple launches
under my belt was like, okay,
I really want to get
into the startup world.
I want to, instead of taking
an existing product to improve
its profitability and reach,
I want to go from zero to one.
I want to help bring new
robotics technologies,
automation technologies into the world
in a way that's actually meaningful and
can provide value, who's doing that?
So there's as in the Boston area and
there's a bunch of robotics
companies in the Boston area and
I knew a few folks out them
from other periods in my life.
But I actually found that there was a GSB
alum on the board of Berkshire Grey and I
just reached out to him and he immediately
got me in conversation with the CEO.
So those sorts of tactical things,
that's how the GSB
alumni network can be extremely
helpful in that regard but,
at a more personal level I
rely on my GSB friends for
advice all the time similar
to what Emily mentioned.
It's a really great support system.
Folks who actually, they might not
be in your direct industry, but
there's lots of corollaries and
they might invest in your industry,
they might have consulted for
companies in your industry.
There's just so many different angles of
attack that you have with your friends and
colleagues and through the GSB network
that you get to develop a really strong
perspective on a space before you even
enter it and that's a huge advantage.
>> Thank you for sharing.
John, while I have you,
there was a question specific to Gmex and
since you had shared that you did a Gmex,
I'd love to direct that towards you.
When doing a Gmex first,
just how easy was it to do?
And if you could talk a little bit about
the support you received from the program
office in terms of the team that
kind of oversees global experiences.
But also,
are you able to customize your experience?
How do you kind of get placed into
a company and things like that?
If you could talk a little bit
more about that, that'd be great.
>> Sure, so in terms of the customization
aspect, that's not a route that I took,
though I'm not sure if it's possible.
I imagine that it is,
I think that there are folks who have
sourced their own genomics opportunities.
But what I did is I think
what majority of people do,
be career office sources a bunch of
opportunities from companies who
are looking to bring GSBers in and
they'll open up a couple of spots.
And there's a huge list and
I would be surprised if all of them get
staffed [LAUGH] because there
seems to be more demand for
GSB talent [LAUGH] than
can be fully supplied.
But yeah, so,
I identified a couple of opportunities and
really what you do is, at least in my
experience is, I chatted with a bunch of
the people who had created those
opportunities in those companies.
And you basically try to find out what's
a good fit for what they're looking for
and what you're looking for.
So it's partially curated
in that there's a certain
amount of value that
the companies are looking for.
They want you to do something for them,
it's not just you go have a fun time,
you actually have to contribute something.
And that's even more
rewarding because of it.
So I remember I was talking
to some folks in Germany,
I forget what they were
doing at this point.
Buenos Aires and there was another
one too, that I spoke with.
But yeah, I really clicked
with the Argentine team and
because they were offering something
that was very product focused.
And at that point I hadn't really
done anything in product management,
my previous internship, so
I did two internships that summer.
I did one in business development
at ESRI earlier in the summer,
which is not product related.
That was much more in my research
wheelhouse from previously.
And then the product one in
Argentina really struck a chord and
I was what they were looking for and
they were what I was looking for.
So that's how it worked out.
I don't know if there's an aspect
of the question that I missed,
but I think that most
>> No, that's great, and
I think because you didn't customize
yours that's absolutely fine, but
just to answer the question there, it is
possible to customize your experience.
Actually, I believe and
if you do head nods, but
I believe that you can
customize not just Gmex.
But let's say a global study trip,
there isn't a global study trip offer
that really is kind of an area or
place you want to focus on or go to, which
is hard to imagine because there's such
a plethora [LAUGH] of choices each year,
but you can also design.
And that's really what the global
experiences team is there for.
They're part of the MBA programs office
and they're there to help you make sure
that you're able to fulfill that
requirement in a way that works for you.
So there are lots of
different ways to do that.
One of the other questions out there, and
I'm going to drag this to each of you to
share, you can share a little bit or
a lot in terms of this.
But for you when you were at the GSB
what did a typical day look like?
And you don't have to
walk through a whole day.
But I think really the question
is getting at how do you
balance studying and clubs and recruiting?
And maybe what some people I always
tell from an admissions perspective and
having interacted with students over the
years, it's like I think a lot of times
you have to choose and prioritize because
time is definitely the biggest commodity.
So maybe if you could share of
an extracurricular activity you
are involved in, just in that way and
as an example of perhaps highlighting
maybe how you spent your time.
And this is largely outside of academics
than what were you involved in?
Geraldo, why don't we start with you.
>> Yeah, I was thinking is like really
taking us back to that time, right?
Before I share the answer, I think our
class started this week in a life of.
So I think it might still be online, so
I would encourage people to read that.
And it really talks through a day to
day breakdown of what someone is going
through.
I think for me, yeah, typical day,
going back to prioritization as a product
person, that's something I'm
constantly thinking about.
So that's how like even
at the GSB approach, but
we used to have that joke, right?
You have your studies, social and
sleep, the three things and
you can choose two out of those
three at a given point in time.
But for me, I think going in,
having a little bit clear picture for me,
socializing, meeting the people
all of that was important.
And it was actually challenging myself
because I had always been so academic.
So a study focused and
only worried about that growing up
in an environment like that was to
actually not worry about the grades.
So, not to say you should
not get good grades but
it's more about what you're learning
out of it versus just ticking a box,
which is what I was
trained to be in the past.
So going to the question of just
how we managed the different times,
I know GSB is also very good
with giving us the focus time.
And it is a recruiting season and stuff or
also delaying people to come on campus
company so you get the time to adjust.
But discovering through
the social piece is important,
I think,
in how we go about the day to day life.
So yeah, definitely it's getting your
goals for the weekly or quarterly and
then focusing on what you want to get
out has been more important to me.
>> Awesome thanks, Emily could you share?
>> Sure, I'll do second year because
second year I really had lots of fun.
And I figured out like to hurls point I
figured out my priorities a little bit
better first year I was sort of like
a chicken with my head cut off.
I didn't really know what I wanted and
there was so
much to do and I wanted to do everything.
But second year, I got very into being
healthy, so I'd wake up really early and
exercise.
I went to ridiculous
Palo Alto exercise classes.
And then there's probably, let's say
on any given day, I had like classes.
So I can be totally honest,
I'd cram in [LAUGH] the case
right before the class.
And make sure that I had some working
knowledge of what was happening when I
walked in.
And honestly, the discussions and
conversations were amazing, but
so there was some portion
of my day that was that.
A lot of portion of my day that was
socializing in the main quad area which I
don't even what was the name
Old Town Square, old square?
What was it?
I don't remember the name, so
no, someone needs to help me out.
>> Town Square.
>> It's Town Square, okay, no I was
combining Town Square with Old Town Road,
I think, that song.
So spending a lot of time there,
eating lunch,
packing in my salad as much
there was an amazing salad deal.
And then I'd probably have two or
three club meetings.
I was really involved in women in
management, so I would do that for
a little bit.
I was involved in the retail club,
so I would do that.
And then I would like hang out with
my roommates and we would plan,
we hosted a lot of small group
dinners at our house, which meant like
Stanford gave us money to bring people
over to our house and have dinner.
And then occasionally we were like maybe
we should also do this with professors.
So we brought professors and had them
come over to our house for dinner.
And then Jason was reminding me there
was some fun parties that we went to,
or just different activities and
leagues and stuff.
So we went to, and I would probably do
that and then I would repeat the next day.
And it was amazing and so much fun.
So that was day in life, I think.
>> Awesome, thank you, Jason.
[LAUGH] She mentioned you.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, I won't share data like because I
was a horrible example of prioritization.
And so my learning goal, you set
learning goals with your groups and
week one of my learning goal that was
forced upon me was to learn to say no.
Because I was, I've always been a yes
person and so I can talk about pretty much
every extra curricular because I was
probably involved and I definitely out of
>> Not just involved, you would lead it,
literally lead it, yeah.
>> And out of the three choices that are
all mentioned, I think I gave up three.
So I definitely pulled way more all
nighters that I would ever recommend just
to plan, the GSB show or plan a study
trip or plan something for folks.
Because I love I just love
the community so much.
So what I will say is,
there's something for everyone.
Whether you want a club around VC or
a club around people who love media and
arts or if you want to club around
robotics or honestly if you want to spend
time at other schools, the law school,
the med school, there's so many choices.
So what I would advise is thinking of your
framework early of what are priorities for
you, which I tell startups all the time,
pick up your OKRs and
don't do anything else.
But think of your priorities and
what you want to say yes to and
truly learn to say no to 80% of
things because there are just so
many options and
it's really tough to prioritize and
you don't want to spread
yourself too thin.
>> Awesome, thanks, and John,
do you want to chime in there?
>> Yeah, sure.
I mean, big plus one [LAUGH] [INAUDIBLE]
Request prioritization [LAUGH] And
figuring out what your goals are.
Because there's way too much going
on to be able to do all of it.
Yeah, I mean for me, yes, class is
usually going on in the mornings, but
I had a couple of classes that
would go on in the evenings.
And in the in between time, I spent
a bunch of time in the practice and
manufacturing club as you might expect.
And a lot of one on one with folks,
especially people who were victim related
industries especially second year
I spent a bunch of time trying to learn as
much about different companies as I could.
So, that could be having coffee chat
with your professor who is a VC and
invests in a couple of
these types of companies.
Or maybe driving up to SF and
going and seeing someone shot and
what they're doing or
going over to Sand Hill Road and
being shown around by the portfolio of
companies by one of the investors there.
There's just, there's a lot of that,
especially second year because for
me in second year was all about
trying to figure out exactly what I'm
going to do when I leave the place.
But also there's a ton of socializing.
I would play tennis with folks often,
multiple times a week and
sometimes volunteer a little bit too.
There's a program called
East Palo Alto Tennis Tutoring which I
would help out with.
There's basically kids would get
tutored and then they would go out and
hit the tennis ball around with some
folks who have volunteered to do so.
And that was, for me that was a little
bit of a grounding experience
because being within the GSB
there's a lot going on and
it feels like its own
world in some respects.
But it's also good to get
out of it a little bit and
then I loved living in my past townhouse.
My housemates and
I spent a lot of time together.
Whether it was having cookouts, or playing
random board games and having folks over.
It was a,
that social experience was probably one of
the most tight knit social
experiences that I had at GSB.
And those are the people that I most
rely on [LAUGH] For advice these days.
But yeah,
there's no shortage of things to do.
>> Awesome, thanks for sharing and just
for those on the cop at pass down house.
Is a term that is used within
the GSB community because
many first year GSB students
will live on campus and
when I say many it's in the high 90%.
They'll either live in buildings that are
directly across the street from the GSB or
other housing available
on the Stanford Campus.
But after that in second year it is common
to move to the area around the campus and
in what they call pass down houses.
Houses that over the years have always
been rented to GSB students and
just continue to be passed down.
So that's that term.
Jason earlier you had
mentioned that you actually
do refer back to your what matters
most question that you answered and
in your application and
we're speaking today to
a bunch of people on this call who were
embarking on that application process.
I'm just curious from the others,
how often you might also think about
your what matters most question,
and whether you use that as an anchor
point ever in your life today.
Maybe Emily, [LAUGH] I see you smiling.
So I don't know if that's a yes or no.
[LAUGH]
>> I'm smiling because I know
someone who's on that,
who's an attendee on this panel who I've
been talking about my what matters most.
>> Okay.
[LAUGH]
>> So with a lot with, so honestly,
I hadn't looked at it in
a really long time and
when I went back to it I was reminded
exactly what I said, which was good.
And you could keep myself honest about,
okay, well how are you living your values?
And I think what I'm really proud of is
that sure it does look like the exact
career path that I thought
was going to connect to that,
maybe I haven't achieved that yet.
But the work I did then to think
about what mattered to me and
it's still threads through
all that I do at work,
all that I do in my personal life.
So without going super into all of you,
100% it's
something that I'm quite proud
of is that I live a life and
I work in my career in a way
that reflects my values.
And so yeah, but I hadn't thought
about it in a really long time.
And as I was going through this
application process with this friend,
I was just reminded that
it was a really exhausting,
it felt exhausting and
vulnerable to go through the application
process because I really
took it seriously.
And I really wanted to think about what
mattered to me, and so I just want for
everybody who's applying right now,
it's going to be okay.
You are going to, it's such a gift to be
able to think about these questions, and
even though it's also so
annoying, I'm sure.
And frustrating and you wish you didn't
have to do it are all the things,
the application process really, I think is
a really good reflection of what Stanford
wants out of Its community members,
and is a really good way for
you to also tests,
do I want what Stanford wants, right?
So application processes okay,
I promise you'll get through it and
then the other side is like
a really beautiful thing.
>> I was going to say plus
one on the essays, yeah,
I have to on mine a couple times,
I think the best advice I got is write
it as if you are really telling that
to yourself, no one else is watching.
And that's kind of when you really
hit that to kind of just answer
that question for me.
Definitely what matter most is
something that is I care a lot about is
around community and profiting others,
especially women and
they coming from a culture,
that I had to fight my way through it.
It's something that is near and
dear that I've always been part of like
I launched Women in Tech at Apple.
Continue to stay involved
the GSB never been in business.
And even right now being
sponsors to those.
But and going to the women's circle
program, Alyssa you mentioned that,
I just joined
The Global Management Board for
it to evangelize that across
different regions to grow that.
So it's definitely a part of who I am.
It doesn't have to always be just
the professional carrier you choose or
like, it's just like how you operate,
what are your values?
What are some things that you deeply care
about that will go with you no matter,
and it's definitely something that
has stayed throughout the journey,
>> Awesome, thanks for sharing.
And John, anything to add to that?
>> Not a whole lot, I mean in terms of
the what matters most here and why.
For me, I haven't referred back to the
actual text that I put in the application,
I think since I wrote it.
But the general [LAUGH]
framework that I wrote
about remains my personal
guidance framework.
So in that sense, yes,
I'm always referring back to like, hey,
why do I want to make this decision and
being very deliberate about it?
I think that, that's really where it
manifests itself most often is A,
when you're faced with a difficult
decision how do you weigh your options?
And B, how do you treat and
interact with people on a daily basis?
And I think GSB's general philosophy
focuses on making sure that when
you do those things you do them
with intention and authenticity.
And to me that's one of my biggest
gains that I got from GSB experience.
>> Awesome, thank you so much.
I do want to do a quick like rapid
response because we only have about two
more minutes.
So if there is anything you wish you could
have done differently because again,
this is a five years out.
So just thinking a lot back to your time,
is there anything you would have
done differently, yes or no?
And then if so, what?
And it can be a really short answer
cause we are strapped for time, but
I'd love to do just like
a rapid response on that.
Jason, do you want to- [LAUGH]
>> I feel like I get all the hard courses
first, but no,
I think I spoke to it earlier.
I think going into first year,
I think second year,
I really did a good job of kind
of thinking about how to say no,
what my priorities are, and
kind of what that framework is.
And also not feeling as rushed and
thinking of life as a series
of incremental steps versus hopping
straight to that perfect spot.
And so I think first year, if I could
have adopted that mentality earlier,
I might have a lot more peace.
[LAUGH] Not feel like scrambling.
>> Yeah, John, how about you?
>> Interestingly, l'm going to go
the opposite of Jason just because
my personality is I usually find my
comfort zone and kind of stay there.
And I think at GSB I pushed myself to
be a little bit more exploratory and
trying new things,
compared to what I would do otherwise.
But I still think I could have gotten
even more out of experience if
I had let my exploration side
of things go a little bit more.
If l spent a little bit
more time socializing,
maybe a little bit less time reading much,
reading.
[LAUGH] Yeah, so
that's what it looks like.
>> Thanks for sharing.
Emily, really quickly.
Wouldn't change.
>> I think it was pretty good, but
if I had to choose I'd say Jason's but
I'd like actually the exact
same thing that Jason said.
Except, I think that was
part of the journey and
that's why I like got to second year and
was able to do second year the way I did.
And I don't know, believe me,
I screwed up and messed things up and
things were hard sometimes but
I think it was all part of the journey.
>> Yeah, awesome, and Heral,
give me a chance to time you.
>> Yeah, I was going to say like
more travel, [LAUGH] of that cons.
But more travel, more to build
the relationships with others, so
it's more one on ones, more small
group dinners and more travel is good.
>> Awesome, thank you so much to all for
of you for being on, we are so
appreciative.
And there's a quick poll just to get some
feedback on the event that we'd love for
everyone who's on to fill out.
I saw so many questions we didn't get to,
some we touched on but others around,
having Master's degrees before coming and
different questions.
I would encourage you to check
out our class profile online and
other resources we have
on the GSB website.
Just so
you can find out more information, and
we encourage you to check our events
web page to come to future events,
and to continue, learning more and
having us support you on your journey.
Again, thank you to our panelists,
you guys were awesome
mini class of 16 reunion.
And I appreciate your time and
thank you to everyone who attended again.
Good morning, good evening,
good afternoon, wherever you are.
Thank you so much for
your time today, everyone.
[MUSIC]